[MUSIC]
In Europe in the 16th century,
most people drank beer instead of water.
The brewing process killed all of those
nasty microbes that were found in your
average 16th century cup of water.
So beer was actually the cheapest
safe beverage available.
When coffee and tea became widely and
cheaply available in Europe,
thanks to the opening of trade routes with
Latin America and east Asia in the 17th
century, they offered a new,
safe alternative to water.
And the subsequent transition from
drinking mostly alcohol to drinking
mostly caffeine coincided with
the most technologically productive
period in the continent's history-
>> [LAUGH]
>> The Industrial Revolution.
I love this correlation
because it illustrates
everything that I love about history.
History pushes us to be curious
about cause and effect.
As a kid, I assumed that these
brilliant scientists and
inventors that I had learned about who
invented the steam engine, who learned
how to harness coal and produce
electricity were solely responsible for
our being ushered into the modern era.
But studying history, real history, messy
history shows a very different story.
Where the Industrial Revolution was
dependent not only on these brilliant
inventors and scientists but
also on Europe's transition
from being permanently drunk
to permanently caffeinated.
>> [LAUGH]
>> History shows us how small changes in
the way that we live our lives can
trigger massive societal transformation.
Historians study the past to uncover the
unintended consequences of our actions.
We're not always encouraged to think
like historians here at the GSB.
In fact, I think most of us would probably
consider ourselves students of the future.
After all, this place is dedicated to
the things that haven't happened yet and
the people who are about to dream them up.
But I think that we all
should think like historians.
See, I think that Silicon Valley needs
to learn how to think like historians.
Here, we only consider the past for long
enough to figure out how to disrupt it.
We're not often preoccupied
with unintended consequences.
And so many of the innovations that we've
built are actually causing bigger problems
than the ones that they set out
to solve in the first place.
To better understand
the impact of our innovation,
we need a better framework for
mapping out cause and effect.
We need to understand
the impacts of our actions.
For example, the National Safety Council
realized that car accidents increased
by 12.3% over a five-year period due
to an increase in distracted driving.
Which is really just a euphemism for not
being able to put your smartphone down.
Or traffic congestion in San Francisco,
it's gotten worse, right,
it's increased by 60%
over the last ten yers.
And more than half of that is
attributed to Uber and Lyft.
And Airbnb is accused of
decreasing long-term housing stock
in cities that are already facing housing
shortages and affordability issues.
So how can we learn to
think like historians
here in Silicon Valley to minimize risk
and to mitigate some of this damage?
Well, thinking like a historian means
looking closely at what we're leaving
behind, first of all.
Historians spend a lot of time digging
through primary source records and
artifacts, which can be broadly
classified into two different categories,
trash and triumph.
Trash is everything that the people
in the past meant to throw away.
Triumph is everything that they
intentionally left behind for us to find.
And both are equally important
in understanding what life was
actually like in the past.
And historians have learned just as much
from ossified food remains as they have
from the hieroglyphs that are carved in
the walls of the ancient pyramids when it
comes to understanding what it was
like to live in ancient Egypt.
Now, I would argue that we spend too
much time focused on the triumph and
not enough time looking at the trash when
it comes to understanding our impact here.
Now, sure, the triumph has an interesting
story to tell about our priorities
as a civilization and a society,
just as the ancient Egyptians built
pyramids to house their dead leader gods.
Jeff Bezos is building a $42 million clock
in the desert as a testament to technology
that will continue to function for
a millennia, sure, interesting story.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But
the trash has a really
important story to tell, too.
The trash tells a story about how our
lives are changing in the most mundane but
often most fundamental ways.
Historians have learned so much about
who was trading with whom by studying
discarded pottery shards and
tracking them through ancient trash dumps.
And we too can learn
about the behaviors and
patterns that our
innovations are encouraging
by studying the things that people
did not intend to leave behind.
What does the refuse in
a ride-share driver's
trunk say about the amount of time
that he has to spend in his car?
What do the deleted direct messages
in a teenage girl's Instagram account
say about the experience of
being a young woman online?
In addition to looking at
what we're leaving behind,
we also have to understand
whom we're leaving out.
We need to ask questions about whose
voices are missing from the stories that
we hear of our impact.
Historians know all too well that there
is no such thing as a reliable narrator.
Everybody's explanation of the fact is
tinged by their own unique perspective.
A horrifying bloodbath and
a justified seizure of power
are both valid descriptions of
the French Revolution depending on
where you were standing in 1789.
The historian's job is to piece
together these multiple perspectives
to get a comprehensive view
of what happened and why.
When it comes to building technology and
developing new ideas, it's easy to lose
sight of that big-picture view and
get trapped in our own perspectives.
Just look at the myriad
tools that we've built
to solve problems that are only
relevant to the urban tech elite.
Think an Uber for dog walking app that's
currently valued at $300 million,
seems a little unnecessary.
We need to ask questions
about whose voices
are missing from our
understanding of the world.
We need to be more curious as
business people and technologists.
What would happen if we stepped out of
the view of our direct customers and
interviewed people who are impacted
by the second-degree effects
of emerging technology,
what might we learn?
There's a sort of historical
hubris here in Silicon Valley.
There's a sense that the things that we're
building are going to change the world,
and we know exactly how and why.
Whenever I hear a tech CEO or
a startup founder or
a venture capitalist talk about how their
company is going to change the world,
I can't help but think about my
favorite little nugget of history.
See, the introduction of
caffeine to the European populace
may have helped to spur
the Industrial Revolution.
But there's no way that
any conquistador or
a merchant could have possibly known that
as they carted bushels of tea leaves and
coffee beans across oceans and deserts.
The introduction of new
goods to the European market
could have very easily pushed
history in a different direction.
Highly relevant to today, the bubonic
plague, which killed every third European
in the middle of the 14th century,
was also a side effect of open trade.
Small changes can trigger
destruction just as easily as
they trigger transformation and
innovation.
We need to better understand our impact,
and
the questions that historians asked to
study the past can help us do this.
Isaac Asimov once said that great
science-fiction writers don't imagine
the car, they imagine the traffic.
I sure wish that Uber had imagined
the traffic when they built their app.
>> [LAUGH]
>> We all need to get better at imagining
and fixing the traffic that
our innovations build.
And the study of history can help
us ask the right questions so
that we're building a future that we all
actually want to live in, thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]